that was the worst conversation of my
life so mckelty called me right as I was
walking down the stairs into the kitchen
she's so excited I'm moving to Utah
and I said yeah I'm excited to move too
and then I heard a gasp
when I looked behind me and there was
truly
Christine Brown in tears after
accidentally revealing to her and Cody's
daughter truly they've split I just know
that I'm gonna remember this moment for
the rest of my life
as the day I broke truly's heart on
Sister Wives after Christine decided to
leave Cody the two are facing a new
challenge how they'll break the news to
their youngest daughter 11 year old
truly I mean I really want to have Cody
and I tell truly together because
I want her to see us as still a team
because she's had friends that whose
parents and have had divorces and it's
been very ugly and a lot of fighting and
I don't want her to think that it's
going to be like that for her and Cody
he has his hesitations about it I've got
to think about telling her I just don't
yeah it's not crap I want her to have to
deal with it 10 years old I know 11 but
she's a smart kid and she is gonna
realize something there's five of us
very five different thinking adults who
are trying to raise kids together have a
family together and we don't see eye to
eye on all things after a little back
and forth Christine ultimately decides
to hold off okay so we'll wait I'm truly
yeah I want to get things arranged I
mean in the end I'm still not going to
tell truly Cody is not ready to tell
truly I want to play nice and I want to
play fair because we need to be a team
we need to move forward as a team we're
going to be co-parenting truly for the
rest of her life but she did Express her
concerns about waiting it's just getting
close so I don't want to accidentally
slip yeah and that kind of happened so
um truly overheard me on the phone with
mckelty stupidly I was talking
downstairs I thought she was anyway
she overheard
that and I said anyway oh God so how did
truly take the news I told her we're
moving and she started to cry I knew
that she hadn't quite clocked that I was
leaving Cody
and rather than let her leave the room
and go process this
she needs to know everything
and I said it's just you and I that are
moving it's just the two of us and she
goes are you and Dad getting divorced
and her little face was so heartbroken
and the situation wasn't any easier for
Christine I have just
said the hardest thing to my little girl
and I don't know what else to say
I don't know what's gonna make it better
it was awful it was awful and now she's
going to have to tell Cody I want a
relationship with my children especially
those who are young and vulnerable so
it's almost like this is just following
a narrative she sets truly up with well
Dad's never here anyway right I mean
she's leading truly down the road I mean
it's easy when you're when you're upset
about things to say well
this is a problem that you created you
know I mean we did it together but
there's it's easy to start pointing the
other ugly finger to blame and so no I
don't just blame myself but I do believe
that as we go through struggles there's
always plenty of blame to spread around
[Music]